[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur lcp
public sénat pour ce nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo l'essentiel de la
semaine politique et parlementaire avec
michael annett bonjour catllar est notre
invité cette semaine et david raffini
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur maire
de fréjus directeur de campagne de
marine le pen est avec vous cette
semaine il ya beaucoup d'actualité bien
on devine devant vérité politique on a
parlé des ralliements série vers
emmanuel macron qui progresse dans les
sondages du nouvel organigramme à droite
après huit semaines de psychodrame et
puis les candidats à passer le grand
oral devant l'association des
départements de france
mais l'actualité politique d'abord avec
cette semaine emmanuel macron qui a reçu
du soutien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont donc nombreux à rallier
emmanuel macron venus de tous horizons
et notamment du parti socialiste valérie
brochard le candidat du mouvement en
marche continue d'attirer les ténors du
parti socialiste c'est l'ancien maire de
paris bertrand delanoë qui annonce en
direct son ralliement il faut donner le
maximum de forces au premier tour au
candidat qui peut battre madame le pen
je pense que le candidat qui se
rapproche le plus de mes convictions de
socialiste réformiste européen réalise
ce emmanuel macron depuis la création du
mouvement en marche
il était déjà quelques-uns à choisir
officiellement emmanuel macron richard
ferrand député socialiste du finistère
gérard collomb sénateur et maire
socialiste de lyon christophe castaner
député socialiste des alpes de haute
provence
plus récemment c'est le candidat
écologiste à la primaire de gauche
françois de rugy qui a confirmé son
soutien
même certains ministres seraient tentés
mais le président de la république leur
a demandé de mettre leurs opinions
politiques de côté pas non plus faire
comme s'il n'y avait pas d' expression
d'un certain nombre de ministres et
c'est légitime dans un moment aux
politiques ou si important nice qu'un
rappel président de la république c'est
que il ya des enjeux politiques majeurs
qui sont ceux des valeurs que nous
portons
et que nous devons défendre jusqu'au
bout on doit être présent pour les
français l'hémorragie tant redoutée au
parti socialiste n'a pas eu lieu
emmanuel macron attire des personnalités
issues de tous les bords politiques
alain madelin figure française du
libéralisme et ancien ministre d'alain
juppé françois bayrou président du modem
robert hue premier secrétaire du parti
communiste de 1994 à 2001 des soutiens
hétéroclite qui conviennent bien à celui
qui se décrit comme le candidat ni de
droite ni de gauche
david rachline qu envoyer tous ses
soutiens notamment bertrand delanoë qui
est sorti sa réserve qui soutenir donc
emmanuel macron ça vous inspire quoi est
ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour lui
pour un candidat qui n'est pas
socialiste en fait les socialistes
derrière lui il y en a d'ailleurs un
certain nombre qu'il est allé chercher
jusque dans le grenier
je sais que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
étaient déjà au gouvernement il ya vingt
ans et nous explique qu'il va changer un
certain nombre de choses qu'il porte un
projet qui va permettre de rénover la
vie politique française avec des gens
qui sont installés dans la vie politique
depuis au moins 20 ans une personnalité
comme jean yves le drian qui annoncerait
dans les prochains jours son ralliement
c'est une personnalité de poids c'était
ma mise à la défense que vous saluer mes
jean-yves le drian il porte sur ses
épaules le lourd bilan de françois
hollande c'est un bon ministre il s'est
battu parfois pour être très honnête
s'il s'est battus parfois pour avoir un
budget qui soit moins à la baisse que ce
que voulaient bercy il n'en reste pas
moins que d'abord qui n'a pas réussi à
obtenir ces budgets pour la défense et
secundo qu'il sait qu'il est solidaire
de la politique et qui lisent solidaire
jusqu'au bout de la politique de rachat
d'actions du tennis de la défense et
toujours du point rejoint emmanuel
macron c'est tout de même extraordinaire
de voir un certain nombre de personnes
nous dire aujourd'hui que la candidature
de monsieur macron va rénover la vie
politique au moment où il est soutenu
par tous ceux qui ont fait cette vie
politique elles sont caractérisées par
ses échecs dramatique mais ça veut dire
une seule chose à me dire qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens autour de
françois hollande qui essaye de se
sauver et de sauver des places et des
prêts bay les prébendes et
c'est aussi une deuxième réalité qu'il
faut constater c'est que monsieur macro
incarnent en fait la continuité la même
politique que monsieur hollande
d'ailleurs on le voit bien sur
l'immigration il a d'abord sur l'union
européenne il est d'accord sur le modèle
économique il est d'arriver à racheter
sur à peu près tous les sujets étaient
entendus à benoît hamon jeudi soir qui
dit qu emmanuel macron serait un
marchepied pour le front national donc
faut pas trop lui taper dessus
non mais une personne et marchepied je
sais pas ce qu'est marchepied du front
national ce sont les échecs de ceux qui
sont au pouvoir depuis depuis 30 ans et
ce sont dans le cadre de cette campagne
le grand débat que nous allons avoir ces
en effet les options patriotes que nous
portons aujourd'hui avec la volonté de
remettre la france au coeur de tout le
représentant les gens vont me le peuple
français au coeur de toute la nation
c'est on pose la question à savoir si
marine le pen pourrait devenir président
je vous pose la question à l'envers
est ce que vous imaginez manuel mâcon
devenir président de la république bah
franchement pas vraiment je crois qu'il
manque singulièrement d'expérience et
surtout je ne vois pas pourquoi on
refait confiance à des gens qui ne
peuvent rien changer
parce que au fond du modèle qu'il
propose et de leur soumission totale à
l'union européenne
ils ne pourront rien changer en réalité
nous pourrons qu'aggraver la situation
c'est cela qui m'inquiète beaucoup
d'ailleurs il ya quand même une
dynamique qui se dessine en verre à
emmanuel macron qui progresse est ce que
ça vous inquiète ou pas du tout je suis
timide qui très relative
je crois qu'il va y avoir un certain
nombre de débats parce que des questions
bien plus important que ne lui sont pas
posées à monsieur macro quid de
l'accueil massif des réfugiés en france
où elle est en position de force dans ce
débat
willis a non non je ne le crois pas je
crois qu'au contraire ce sera un moment
de vérité
quid de l'immigration massive et de
l'accueil des réfugiés il appelle
manifestement de ses voeux quid du
modèle économique
pourquoi ce refus du patriotisme
économique pourquoi cette volonté
d'assassiner nos entreprises avec une
concurrence déloyale insupportable lui
il veut aller dans ce sens là et nous
nous opposons à cela un modèle patriotes
clair ou à écouter emmanuel macron qui
les aliments à gauche mais il ya aussi
un petit appel du pied à droite écoutez
je voulais ici saluer celui qui est un
grand responsable politique français qui
est aujourd'hui un maire respecter et
qui a transformé très profondément sa
ville je voulais ici
sans plus en rajouter mais dire mon
estime
lorsqu'on à sa carrière qu'on a eu son
engagement reconnaître le besoin qu'a
aujourd'hui notre pays à la fois de
renouvellement et en même temps
d'extrême probité ça n'était pas facile
et il l'a fait il ya très peu de gens
qui sont capables de faire ça voilà
c'est un coup tactique il aux orphelins
d'alain juppé j'ai renouvellement avec
alain juppé ça va quand même être un
petit peu compliqué non je crois que ma
kron a autour de lui tous ceux qui
veulent maintenir les puissants là où
ils sont c'est le candidat des banques
c'est le candidat d'un certain nombre de
médias c'est le candidat de ceux qui
sont là le bénéfice de cette
mondialisation
ils sont quelques-uns tandis que le
peuple français souffrent énormément de
cette idée alors ça préfigure
certainement de ce qu'on entendra
pendant le débat entre les candidats
actualité à présent à droite avec le
nouvel organigramme notamment annoncé
par françois fillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et après des semaines de psychodrame
nouvelle équipe et nouvel homme fort
notamment avec la présence de françois
baroin dans l'organigramme et françois
baroin d'ailleurs qui était en meeting à
châteaurenard dans les bouches-du-rhône
cécile martèle la rentrée unité de
façade ou rapprochements à marche forcée
hier à châteaurenard la droite se
voulait unis autour de françois baroin
pour défendre françois fillon notre chef
c'est françois et c'est notre devoir de
faire gagner la famille gaulliste autour
de françois fillon
en pleine crise son nom a circulé comme
possible plan b mais françois baroin a
toujours affiché sa loyauté à françois
fillon
alors aujourd'hui il se positionne au
rassembleur de sa famille politique
je m'emploierai là où je suis à ses
côtés à la place qui sera la mienne et
qui l'aura décidé à rassembler notre
famille de la droite et du centre
je prendrai tous les contacts je ne
ménagerai aucune heure aucune journée
pour discuter pour voir pour travailler
sur ses terres du sud très sarkozyste
l'implication de françois barois rassure
les militants je pense que c'est un
symbole fort de comment dirais-je de
rapprochement et de réunification ou du
moins de tentative de réunification et
on espère qu'elle se soldera par par une
réussite que la mayonnaise prendra bien
dimanche ça nous a donné de l'espoir il
faut contre à militer pour rassembler
les brebis égarées
mais la volte face de certains élus
passent mal
christian estrosi parle du nécessaire
rassemblement contre le front national
mais ne fait l'éloge que de françois
baroin merci de nous rassembler ce soir
françois on a vraiment besoin de toi
aux côtés de françois fillon merci
françois baroin d'après une récente
enquête d'opinion françois baroin
désormais une cote de popularité plus
élevée que celle de françois fillon chez
les sympathisants de droite
parmi ces nouvel organigramme on a bien
l'impression françois fillon fait une au
ph et sarkozyste coûté en tout cas je
vois que monsieur estrosi s'est fait lui
et dans sa propre région c'est donc que
ils sont quand même encore à couteaux
tirés
manifestement il assure estrosi qui est
à la tête d'une cellule de riposte
contre vous construit semble-t-il
semble-t-il
en tout cas je crois que il sera très
difficile pour monsieur fillon d'avoir
sa famille politique rassemblée autour
de lui et vu les débats assez dur qu'il
ya eu ces dernières semaines le problème
essentiel de monsieur fillon étant son
bilan son bilan qui a été absolument
catastrophique je suppose qu'on va en
reparler mais 2500 postes de policiers
et de gendarmes en moins l'avancée du
communautarisme continue la soumission
totale là encore l'union européenne et
c'est en cela qu'il est un peu
interchangeables d'ailleurs avec
monsieur macron puisque sur tous les
grands événements enfin comme sur tous
les grands sujets fondamentaux ils sont
d'accord il propose à peu près peu ou
prou les mêmes choix aussi la
personnalité qui compte quand même dans
une élection présidentielle et françois
fillon se met debout contre vents et
marées qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa
liste noire je sais pas si vous le voyez
de boom gelé vue plutôt fuyant ces
dernières semaines par en capacité de
rassembler sa famille politique
dimanche et à bina moi je crois que oui
bien sûr que son image est animé parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de suspicions
qui pèsent sur lui y compris
d'enrichissement personnel qui est assez
grave en fait et donc sur cette question
justement david rachline cette semaine
la ministre de l'éducation nationale
najat vallaud belkacem a dit hier que
françois fillon comme marine le pen
passer leur temps à se soustraire à la
justice
vous savez je crois que il s'agit pas
faux il était convoqué ce vendredi
il s'agit là d'une accélération du tempo
judiciaire et d'une accélération du
tempo médiatique qui correspond et qui
est très étonnant à quelques semaines de
passer son temps à se soustraire à
ajuster et qui est très étonnant à
quelques semaines d'une élection
présidentielle
donc moi je fais ce constat et en ce qui
concerne marine elle a expliqué de
manière extrêmement claire qu'elle était
prête à répondre à tous ceux qui lui
poserait les camions après l'élection
présidentielle at on rappelé de choses
quand même vous rappeler qu'il y a un an
elle a demandé sur la sphère dit les
assistants au parlement européen combat
qui est politique qui est menée par le
parlement européen
elle a demandé l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire il y a un an pas
d'ouverture d'information judiciaire
l'ouverture et les procédures se sont
réalisées d'exemple la guérilla il ya
quelques jours se changerait évidemment
de brut donc ça veut dire que pour vous
les candidats une présidentielle ne doit
pas être à la merci de la justice si je
puis dire
mais il faut évidemment que la justice
fasse son travail mais pourquoi
et là il ya un fait précis pourquoi la
justice n'a t'elle pas ouvert cette
information judiciaire
elle respecte la juste il y a un an et
marine avait écrit pour ouvrir cette
information judiciaire justement pour
pouvoir avoir accès au dossier et
s'expliquer et tout se passe ces
perquisitions qui sont un petit peu
médiatique d'ailleurs se passe quelques
semaines avant l'élection présidentielle
tout ça n'a pas de sens
marine répondra en temps voulu
évidemment vous mettez c'est un petit
peu de côté jury une question également
ce qu'on a vu cette semaine notamment
des incidents en seine saint denis est
là aussi
la gauche dit que et françois fillon et
notamment bernard cazeneuve et françois
hollande qui vous attaquent en disant
que la gauche comme la droite par donc
comme le front national ait said
d'instrumentaliser un petit peu ces
incidents non on instrumentalise rien du
tout et nous nous avons dit que françois
fillon porté une grande responsabilité
dans le désordre qui règne aujourd'hui
la gauche aussi bien sûr mais d'abord
françois fillon qui à supprimer 2500
postes de policiers et gendarmes je le
disais tout à l'heure et 70000 personnel
des forces de l'ordre en général jusqu'à
l'armée la défense et les douaniers etc
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas une commune qui ne soit pas touchée
par une forte insécurité par des
troubles qui sont très importants nos
lycées nos transports mais la réponse
est censé communication des effectifs
bien sûr c'est d'abord l'augmentation
pour ces actifs
et puis c'est la fin du lac seul homme
la république de la justice parce que
les hommes et il y a beaucoup à faire il
faut que les délinquants du quotidien
sachent qu'ils seront systématiquement
condamné alors qu'aujourd'hui on le sait
bien les policiers font le travail
il récupère les délinquants et ils sont
relâchés au bout de quelques semaines
former président de la république a fait
du combat contre le front national
son dernier combat dans ces élections
passées on aurait aimé qu'il fasse du
combat contre le chômage du combat
contre l'insécurité du combat pour
réformer notre modèle économique est
l'un de ses derniers combats pas plus
qu'il n'a été capable de le faire
ces dernières années il ne sera capable
de le faire les prochains mois
évidemment il est assez scandaleux de
voir que le prix dans la république n'a
rien d'autre à faire que d'utiliser les
moyens de l'état d'ailleurs pour faire
campagne contre et fait campagne qui
représente plusieurs millions
d'électeurs il fait campagne contre vous
bah écoutez en tout cas c'est lui qu'ils
annoncent donc nous attendons de voir
enfin très honnêtement si monsieur
hollande fait campagne contre nous je
pense que c'est à prendre comme un bon
signe parce que ça veut dire qu'on
s'oppose à sa politique et que donc nous
sommes sur la bonne voie
alors david rachline cette semaine il y
avait du monde à l'assemblée du beau
monde puisque étaient accueillis ici le
congrès des départements de france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les candidats ou leurs représentants
vous même d'aller en chine étaient venus
présenter leurs idées et leur feuille de
route pour les départements de france le
plus vieil échelons de la république
astrid de vilaines grand oral à
l'assemblée pour les candidats à la
présidentielle sur le thème des
départements première mesure assumée par
emmanuel macron réduire le nombre de
départements pour les rapprocher des
métropoles vous savez j'ai fixé à cet
égard l'objectif de réduire d'un quart
le nombre de départements à l'horizon
cette réforme elle ne sera ni mécanique
ni unilatérale mais elle n'aurait
répondra pas une logique administrative
mais à une logique de projet de
territoire une mesure vivement critiquée
par le représentant du front national
pas étonnant la part d'un mondialiste
qui doit se sentir sans doute plus
proche d'un cadre new-yorkais ou d'un
bouquet de la citic d'un agriculteurs
aveyronnais ou d'un ouvrier mosellan à
propos des dotations aux collectivités
locales benoît hamon assure qu'il n'y
touchera pas ce qui est certain c'est
que la méthode utilisée ces dernières
années concernant le gel puis la baisse
des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités locales mais plus de
nabeul n'est plus soutenable
le représentant de jean luc mélenchon
propose lui d'augmenter leur budget deux
candidats prévoit une baisse des
dotations pour les collectivités locales
emmanuel macron hauteur de 10 milliards
d'euros en cinq ans 7 milliards d'euros
pour françois fillon qui promet en
échange plus de flexibilité
l'état de son côté doit s'engager à
alléger fortement les contraintes qui
pèsent sur les collectivités en
réduisant les normes imposées ainsi que
toutes les politiques transférés
inutilement ou sans financement autres
sujets abordés au cours de cette matinée
le mode de scrutin aux élections
départementales vivement critiquée par
les candidats dits anti système
le mode de scrutin qui a été adoptée
pour les
les départements je le dis est une
calamité deux par canton mais c'est
n'importe quoi
je ne comprends pas comment on a pu
inventer un truc aussi absurde et bill
emmanuel macron et benoît hamon se sont
également prononcés pour une
recentralisation du rsa actuelle
compétences du département
david raging est ce que le front
national a trouvé la bonne formule la
martingale pour réduire ce qu'on appelle
le mécano théâtrale millefeuille
territorial oui je pense marine a
annoncé de grandes réformes
institutionnelles qui consistera d'abord
un baisser le nombre de députés de
sénateurs à 3 100 et 200 mais au niveau
des collectivités territoriales elle
veut s'appuyer sur les départements et
sur les plus de régions plus de régions
en effet ce sera source de grandes
économies oui il faut revenir sur cette
loi notre 12e 13 régions les communes et
leurs compétences et les maires sont
contournées il faut donner un vrai
statut au maire il faut rendre aux
communes leurs compétences qui
n'empêchera pas des associations entre
les communes quand elles veulent
évidemment travailler ensemble mais il
faut supprimer les doublons supprimer
les ceser supprimer toutes ces dépenses
qui font que les autres l'ailé que les
augmentations d'impôts au niveau local
se succèdent
il faut s'appuyer sur marine veut une
révolution de la proximité elle veut que
les maires et les présidents de
départements et les conseillers
territoriaux puisse rendre des comptes
directement aux français je crois que
oui c'est la mode est fort pas de
suppression du département c'est un
petit peu votre action malheur tout pas
surtout pas la suppression de n'est pas
l'argument 15 s'appuyer sur les
départements parce que c'est un échelon
de proximité ça des chenaux où les élus
sont responsables devant les français et
devant les habitants de nos territoires
et c'est un cadre donc parfaite
performant pour récupérer d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de compétences qui ne
seront plus gérées par les régions
puisqu'elles auront disparu par exemple
lycées et d'autres compétences seront
rendues à l'état
ce sera par exemple le même nombre de
fonctionnaires territoriaux mais vous
touchez pas une fois que les régions
auraient été supprimés les compétences
reprises par les départements les
fonctionnaires qui s'occupait de ses
problématiques au niveau des régions
iront vers les départements et pour des
sargasses vous toucherez redéploiement
par mission et cela fera des économies
parce que nous pourrons ne pas remplacer
un certain nombre de départs en retraite
au vu de la fin de ces doublons donc les
départs en retraite ne seront pas
remplacés qu un certain nombre
c'était bien faire des économies on voit
bien le coup mais est bien entendu de
tous ces échelons et d'ailleurs nous
avons chiffré faire tellement de ce que
dit françois fillon d'ailleurs nous
avons chiffré cela puisque nous comptons
faire sur les dépenses inutiles des
administrations à peu près 10 milliards
d'économies en cinq ans avec la réforme
territoriale institutionnels dont je
vous parlais à l'instant la suppression
des doublons des ceser la
rationalisation des strates
administratives et la répartition
extrêmement claire des compétences comme
marine le souhaitent alors on va passer
à notre partenaire du figaro jean
chérasse est avec nous cette allure
d'une seconde dimon joueront kakavand
caccia bonjour là bonjour fine on
parlait de sondages tout à l'heure ils
sont unanimes pour le premier tour ils
donnent tous
marine le pen en tête ou presque par
contre pour le second tour ma le pen est
battu dans tous les cas de figure
comment espérez-vous david rachline avec
marino can briser ce fameux plafond de
verre dont on parle depuis des années au
front national et qui finalement existe
toujours
je pense honnêtement que les sondages de
second tour qui en lieu avant que le
premier tour ait lieu non pas vraiment
d'intérêt majeur mais en tous les cas
notre volonté est compris dans le cadre
de ce second tour ce sera de rassembler
l'ensemble des français autour du projet
de marine autour des 144 engagements
qu'elle porte autour de cette majorité
présidentielle qu'elle veut créer avec
les gens comme ils sont du front
national bien sûr mais aussi avec des
gens qui ne sont pas issus de la
régionale sugar élevé une majorité très
issus de la droite traditionnelle par
exemple les électeurs de françois fillon
vous allez vous adresser directement à
eux dans l'autre de tournage à metz et
puis on n'est pas bien sûr qu on
s'adressera à eux mais aussi à tous les
français à tous les français qui veulent
replacé au centre du débat la france au
centre du débat
notre nation aujourd'hui les
représentants du pouvoir et des vieux
partis du système ont donné la clé du
milieu ont donné la clé du pouvoir à
bruxelles
nous voulons nous rendre sa souveraineté
au peuple français sa souveraineté
monétaire sa souveraineté budgétaire de
sondages sa souveraineté législatives ne
passe pas
mais la fin de la campagne qu'on ait eu
le temps de développer nos avants
content qu'on ait eu le temps
d'expliquer que avec l'euro nous avons
la zone économique au monde qui a le
moins de croissance avec l'euro nous
avons 6 millions cherchez millions et
demi d'agents de droite ou de gauche qui
centre l'ensemble des propositions qui
sont les nôtres et y compris évidemment
cette modification du modèle économique
qui fait tant souffrir le peuple
français aujourd'hui jamais françois
fillon ne se qualifie pas ce qui ce
semble être le cas aujourd'hui dans les
sondages
est ce que vous attendez de sa part qui
clarifie sa position entre l'auto c'est
à dire qu'ils qu'il appelle à voter pour
le front républicain ou bien qui se
prononce en faveur de marine le pen
qu'est ce que vous attendez de sa part
et les électeurs n'appartiennent à
personne et il s'agira pour nous d'aller
nous adresser à tous ceux qui sont
orphelins en effet pour les convaincre
de la pertinence du projet de marine
vous vous rappelez que je ne crois pas
que les annonces
j'appelle à voter pour untel ou untel
porte à voter pour le candidat le moins
sektaoui oui très bien bien alors il
appellera sans doute à voter pour nous
car nous sommes beaucoup moins sectaire
que monsieur macro et nous portons cette
volonté de large majorité présidentielle
avec en son sein des gens je vous le
disais du front mais aussi des gens qui
n'en soit pas pour élargir votre cercle
vous chercher à rassembler aussi du du
côté de la droite traditionnelle on l'a
dit vous cherchez à rallier des
personnalités comme nicolas dupont
aignan henri guaino est ce que ça
pourrait faire des ministres d'un
éventuel gouvernement front national une
majorité élargie peut-être audition au
parlement
pourquoi pas en effet et d'ailleurs nous
avons déjà pris un certain nombre de
nous avons déjà montré notre capacité de
rassemblement prends l'exemple
régulièrement de mon département où
jérôme rivière ancien député ump sera
candidat aux législatives et sera un
député de notre majorité des maires sans
étiquette qui nous rejoignent
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'étaient pas engagés
politiquement par le passé mais qui
disent on a été trompé par les partis du
système depuis des années nous voulons
réformer véritablement notre pays et
changer la politique de ce pays
c'est avec marine qu'on le fera et ils
sont nombreux les
ancien député ou ceux qui souhaitent le
devenir à penser cela donc oui nous
comptons sur cette présidentielle mais
nous ouvrons nos portes à tous ceux qui
veulent remettre et rendre la parole au
peuple français lui rendre la parole en
revitalisant la démocratie en permettant
les pour leur donner des actifs
oculaires en première temps la
proportionnelle intégrale à toutes les
élections c'est nous qui sommes les
véritables républicain filtrante
patriots et entraîneur comment
progressiste contre patriotes non non
patriotes contre mondialistes patriotes
contre ceux qui ont donné encore une
fois les clés du pouvoir à l'union
européenne à bruxelles et à tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont soutenus par les
puissants de ce pays et vous pensez que
mon patriotes ça ça résonne dans
l'esprit des gens c'est encore moi je le
sens moi je le pense parce que je
constate tous les jours que les français
sont maintenant conscients qu'ils ne
sont plus maîtres de leur destin ils
sont conscients que 80% des lois mais
sont des retranscriptions en droit
français des directives européennes qui
ajoute des normes qui ajoutent des
difficultés sur le plan administratif
pour nos entreprises
les collections plus justement ceux à
qui vous fait peur à votre avis
peut-être à l'institut montaigne qui
était dirigée jusqu'à ces derniers mois
par henri de castres qui est un des
principaux soutiens de monsieur fillon
mais je ne crois pas que notre projet
fasse pour la santé le projet qui doit
faire soeur et moi ce dont j'ai très
peur c'est du projet de ceux qui se
présentent aux suffrages des français
mais chez makro nahla fillon qui dans ce
domaine ont un bilan calamiteux alors
justement marine le pen de soutenir les
petites entreprises les petits échelons
je propose d'écouter ce qu'elle a
déclaré cette semaine écoutez il faut
compatriotes si ce n'est pas du
protectionnisme intelligent on va
recréer les conditions de l'emploi
autour des tpe et des pme parce que ce
sont elles qui créent l'emploi et à ce
moment là évidemment on va pérenniser
de fait les retraites parce que plus il
ya d'emplois plus de cotisants comme
c'est un système par répartition plus de
cotisants et bien et plus il y a
évidemment d'argent à distribuer les
petites entreprises c'est le bon échelon
bien sûr les petites et moyennes
entreprises des artisans les commerçants
c'est l'essentiel des emplois dans notre
pays et il faut alléger la complexité
administrative et fiscale qui pèse sur
ces entreprises avec un guichet unique
dédié un guichet unique fiscale
administratif social la généralisation
du titre emploi service
la baisse des obligations
administratives qui sont liées au seuil
sociale de 50 salariés un taux réduit
que nous allons maintenir pour l'impôt
sur les sociétés de 15% mais un taux
intermédiaire qui me restera à 24% alors
qu'il est aujourd'hui ses positions
le medef aussi c'est une première oui
c'est une bonne chose mais bien sûr
c'est une bonne chose puisque nous
voulons nous l'ont dit une étape de la
normalisation de foule immense est pas
mais nous voulons nous adresser à
l'ensemble des entreprises de notre pays
et nous ne voulons pas la ruine des
grandes entreprises nous disons
simplement pour la séquence mais
s'ajuste pas que notre priorité des
priorités ce sont sept entreprises ce
sont ces petites et moyennes entreprises
message à la droite libérale que vous
agressez aussi rejoignez nous on nous
croyons qu'il faut aussi éminemment des
grandes entreprises multinationales qui
représente la france et l'excellence de
la france dans le monde
mes doigts ils doivent savoir que la
priorité des priorités pour nous c'est
évidemment de soutenir notre tissu
industriel et ses petites et moyennes
entreprises toutes les propositions de
marine sont concentrés autour de cette
question très rapidement le poulpe
suisse garde builder
mène la campagne des législatives du 15
mars au pays bas est ce que vous allez
regarder de près ce scrutin qui va se
dérouler à 40 jours au sommet de la
bulle du premier tour pour y trouver des
signaux peut-être oui de très près car
nous le voyons bien partout en europe se
lève un certain nombre de peuples et ce
monde nouveau
marine en est elle appartient ce monde
nouveau elle appartient à ceux qui vont
discuter demain avec madame theresa may
avec les futurs dirigeants européens tu
pourrais être monsieur ville que pour
être bien sûr que ça nous espérons sa
victoire évidemment une majorité de
néerlandais souhaitent semble-t-il
aujourd'hui la sortie de l'union
européenne en tout cas sa réforme sur
bien des sujets et nous le voyons bien
partout en europe les peuples européens
sont conscients et qu'ils sont malmenés
par l'union européenne et que cela cause
des troubles extrêmement grave dans le
domaine économique dans le domaine
social est évidemment dans des versions
identité et nous reste ce que les
nations petite dernière question on a
beaucoup parlé dans des journaux du
retour possible de jean marie le pen le
1er mai avec marine le pen il paraît que
jean marie le pen a donné son parrainage
à marine le pen je crois pas que ce soit
présent c'est pas ses portes à vue c'est
pas d'actualité dans les pas de
réconciliation possible mais c'est pas
une question de conciliation de
réconciliation c'est une question
le mind statue de jeanne d'arc a tranché
et qui avait des désaccords et qu'elle a
dit qu'elle était ces désaccords et ne
reviendra pas dessus
eh bien merci david rachline à l'heure
actuelle la russie le parlement a beau
très bonne fille de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
bye
[Musique]